let's go back to the boat with the with
the fisherman who's tuned out long ago
let's talk to the programmer let's jump
around and go back to see python that we
tried to Define as the reference
implementation and one of the big things
that's coming out in 3.11 what's the
right way we tend to say 3.11 because it
really was like we went 3.8 3.9 3.10
3.11 ends are planning to go up to 3.99
99 what happens after 99 probably just
3.100 what if I make it there okay
and go all the way to 420. I got it
forever python V3 we'll talk about four
but more for fun
so 3.11 is coming out one of the big
sexy things in it is it'll be much
faster so how did you beyond hiring a
great team or working with a great team
make it faster what are some ideas
uh that may makes it faster
it has to do with Simplicity of software
versus performance
and so even though C is known to be a
low-level language which is
great for writing sort of a high
performance language interpreter
when I originally started python or C
python
I
didn't expect there would be
great
success and fame in my future
uh so I
I try to get something working
and useful
uh in about three months
and so I I sort of I cut corners
I borrowed ideas left and right when it
comes to language design as well as
implementation
uh I also wrote much of the code as
simple as it could be
and
they're they're like
there are many things that you can code
more efficiently by adding more code
it's a bit of a sort of a time space
trade-off
where you can compute a certain thing
from a small number of inputs
uh and every time you get presented with
new input
uh you do the whole computation from the
top
that can be simple looking code it's
easy to understand it's easy to reason
about that you can you can tell quickly
that it's correct in at least in the the
sort of mathematical sense of correct
uh because it's implemented in C maybe
it performs relatively well
but over time as sort of
as the requirements for that code and
the need for performance
go up
you might be able to rewrite that same
algorithm
using more memory maybe remember
previous results
so you don't have to recompute
everything from scratch like the the
classic example is Computing prime
numbers
like
is 10 a prime number
well you sort of is it divisible by two
is it divisible by three is it divisible
by four and we go all the way to is it
divisible by nine
and it is not well actually 10 is
divisible by two so that we stop but say
11. it's divisible by ten the answer is
nine is no ten times in a row so now we
know 11 is a prime number
on the other hand if we already know
that 2 3 5 and 7 are prime numbers and
you know a little bit about the
mathematics of how prime numbers work
you know that if you have a rough
estimate for the square root of 11
you don't actually have to check is it
divisible by four or is it divisible by
five you all you have to check in the
case of 11 is is it divisible by 2 is it
divisible by three
because take 12.
if it's divisible by 4 well 12 divided
by 4 is 3 so you you should have come
across the question is it divisible by
three first
so if you know basically nothing about
prime numbers except the definition
maybe you go for X from 2
through n minus 1 is n divisible by X
and then at the end if you got uh all
nodes for every single one of those
questions you know oh it must be a prime
number well the first thing is you can
stop iterating when you find a yes
answer
and the second is you can also stop
iterating when you have have reached
the square root of n because you know
that if it has a divisor larger than
than the square root did not also have a
divisor smaller than the square root
then you say oh except for two we don't
need to bother with checking for even
numbers because all even numbers are
divisible by two so if it's divisible by
four
we would already have come across the
question is it divisible by two and so
now you go special case check is it
divisible by two and then you just check
3 5 7 11.
uh and so now you've you've sort of
reduced your search Space by 50 Again by
by skipping all the even numbers it kept
for two
if you think a bit more about it or you
just
read in your book about the history of
math one of the first algorithms ever
written down
all you have to do is check is it
divisible by any of the previous prime
numbers that are smaller than the square
root
and before you get to a better algorithm
than that
you have to have several phds in in
discrete math so that's as much as I
know so of course that same story
applies to a lot of other algorithms
string matching is a good example of how
to come up with an efficient algorithm
and sometimes yeah the more efficient
algorithm is not so much more complex
than the inefficient one but that's an
art and it's not always the case in the
general cases the more performant the
algorithm the more complex it's going to
be there's a there's a kind of trade-off
the simpler algorithms are also the ones
that people invent first
because when you're looking for a
solution
you look at the simplest way to get
there first
and so if there is a simple solution
even if it's not the best solution not
the fastest or the memory most memory
efficient or whatever
a a simple solution and simple is is
fairly subjective but mathematicians
have also thought about sort of what is
a good definition for simple in the case
of algorithms
uh but the simpler the simpler Solutions
tend to be
easier to follow for other programmers
who haven't made a study of a particular
field and when I when I started with
python I I was a good programmer in
general I knew sort of basic data
structures and new to C language pretty
well
but there were many areas where I was
only somewhat familiar with the state of
the art
and so I I picked
in many cases the simplest way I could
solve a particular sub problem because
when you when you're designing and
implementing a language you have to like
you have many hundreds of little
problems to solve
and you have to have solutions for every
one of them before you can can sort of
say I've invented a programming language
first of all so see python what kind of
things does it do it's an interpreter it
takes in this readable language that we
talked about that is python what is it
supposed to do The Interpreter basically
it's it's sort of a recipe for
understanding recipes
so instead of a recipe that says bake me
a cake we have a recipe for
well given
the text of a program
how do we run that program and and that
is sort of the recipe for building a
computer the recipe for the Baker and
the chef yep what are the
algorithmically tricky things that
happen to be low-hanging fruit that
could be improved on maybe throughout
the history of python but also now how
is it possible that 3.11 in year 2022
it's possible to get such a big
performance Improvement
we focused
on a few areas where we we still felt
there was low hanging fruit
the biggest one is actually The
Interpreter itself
and this has to do with details of Pi
how python is defined so I didn't know
if the fisherman is going to follow this
story he already he already jumped off
the boat he's uh he's he's he's this
yeah stupid python is actually even
though it's always called an interpreted
language it's there's also a compiler in
there it just doesn't compile to machine
code it compiles to bytecode which is
assertive code for an imaginary computer
that is called the python interpreter so
it's compiling code that is more easily
digestible by The Interpreter or it's
digestible at all it is the code that is
digested by The Interpreter that's the
compiler we tweaked very minor bits of
the compiler almost all the work was
done in The Interpreter
because
when you have a program you compile it
once and then you run the code a whole
bunch of times
or maybe there's one function in the in
the code that gets run many times
now I know that that sort of people who
who know this field are expecting me to
at some point say we built a just in
time compiler actually we didn't we just
made The Interpreter uh a little more
efficient what's it just in time
compiler that is a thing from the Java
World although it's now applied to
almost all uh programming languages
especially interpreted ones so you see
the compile inside python not like a
just-in-time compiler but is it compiler
that creates by code that is then
fed to The Interpreter
and the compiler
was there something interesting to say
about the compiler it's interesting that
you haven't changed that tweak that at
all or much we changed some parts of the
byte code
but not very much and so we only had to
change the parts of the compiler where
we decided that the the breakdown of a
Python program in bytecode instructions
had to be slightly different
but
that did that didn't gain us the
performance uh improvements that
performance improvements were like
making The Interpreter faster in part by
sort of
removing the fat from some internal data
structures used by The Interpreter but
the key idea is an Adaptive specializing
interpreter
let's go what is adaptive about it what
is specialized about it well let me
first talk about the specializing part
because the Adaptive part is the sort of
the second order effect but they're both
important so bytecode
is a bunch of machine instructions but
it's an imaginary machine but the
machine can do things like call a
function
add two numbers
print value
those are sort of typical instructions
in Python
uh and if we take the example of adding
two numbers
actually in Python the language there's
no such thing as adding two numbers
there's just an the the compiler
doesn't know that you're adding two
numbers you might as well be adding two
strings or two lists
uh or two instances of some user-defined
class that happen to implement this
operator called add
that's a very interesting and and fairly
powerful mathematical concept it's
mostly a user interface trick because it
means that
a certain category of functions
can be written using a symbols single
symbol the plus sign
and sort of a bunch of other functions
can be written using another single
symbol the multiply sign
uh so if we take addition the way
traditionally in Python the ad byte code
was executed is
pointers pointers and more pointers so
first we we have two objects an object
is basically a pointer to a bunch of
memory that contains more pointers
pointers all the way down
quite but there there are a lot of them
so to simplify a bit uh we look up in
one of the objects
what is the type of that object and does
that object type Define an add operation
and so you can imagine that there is a
sort of a type integer that knows how to
add itself to another integer and there
is a type floating Point number that
knows how to add itself
to another floating Point number
and the integers and floating Point
numbers are sort of important I think
mostly historically because in the first
computers
uh you use the sort of the same bit
pattern when interpreted as a floating
Point number had a very different value
than when interpreted as an integer can
I ask a dumb question here please do
given the basics of ant and float and
add who carries the knowledge of how to
add two integers is it the integer it's
the type integer versus it's the type
integer and the type float what about
the operator is the operator
just exists as a platonic form possessed
by uh the operator is more like
it's an index in a list of functions
that the integer type defines
and so the integer type
is really a collection of functions and
there is an add function and there's a
multiply function and there are like 30
other functions for other operations
there's a power function for example
and you can imagine that
in in memory there is a distinct slot
for the add operations let's say the add
operation is the first operation of a
type and the multiply is the second
operation of a type
so now we take the integer type and we
take the floating Point type
in both cases the add operation is the
first slot and multiplies the second
slot but
each slot contains a function and the
functions are different because the the
add to integers function interprets the
bit patterns as integers that add to
float
function interprets the the same bit
pattern
as
as a floating Point number and then
there is the string
data type which again interprets the the
bit pattern as a
the address of a of a sequence of
characters there are lots of lies in
that story but that's that's sort of a
basic idea I can tell I can tell the
fact the fake news and the fabrication
going on here at the table but uh
where's the optimization is it on the
operator is it a different so inside the
integer optimization is the observation
that
in a particular line of code
so now you you write your little Python
program and you write a function and
that function sort of takes a bunch of
inputs and at some point
it adds two of the inputs together
now I bet you even if you call your
function a thousand times
that all those calls are likely all
going to be about integers because maybe
your program is all about integers or
maybe
on that particular line of code where
there's that plus operator
every time the program hits that line
the variables A and B that b are being
added together happen to be strings
and so what we do is instead of having
this single byte code that says here's
an ad operation and the implementation
of add is fully generic it looks at the
object from the object it looks at the
type then it takes the type and it looks
at looks up the function pointer then it
calls the function now the function has
to be has to look at the other argument
and has to double check that the other
argument has the right type
and then there's a bunch of error
checking before it can actually
just go ahead and add the two bit
patterns in the right way
what we do is
every time we execute an ad instruction
like that
we we keep a little note of
in the end after after we hit the code
that that did the addition
for a particular type what type was it
and then after a few times through that
code if it's this if it's the same type
all the time
uh we say oh so this add operation even
though it's the generic ad operation it
might as well be the add integer
operation and add integer operation is
uh much more efficient because it just
says
assume that A and B are integers do the
addition operation do it right there
inline and produce the result
and the big lie here is that in Python
even if you have great evidence that in
the past it was always too integers that
you were adding at some point in the
future that same line of code could
still be hit with two floating points or
two strings or maybe a string and an
integer it's not a great lie that's just
the fact of life
I didn't account for what what should
happen in that case in in the way I told
the story there is some accounting for
that and and so what we actually have to
do is when we have the add integer
operation
we still have to check
are the two arguments in fact integers
we applied some tricks to make those
checks efficient
and we know statistically that the
outcome is almost always yes it they
were they are both integers
uh and so we quickly make that check and
then we proceed with the the sort of add
integer operation and then there is a
fallback mechanism where we say oops one
of them wasn't an integer
now we're going to pretend that there
was just a fully generic ad operation we
wasted a few Cycles believing it was
what was going to be two integers and
then we had to back up but we didn't
waste that much time and statistically
uh most of the time
basically we were sort of
hoping that most of the time we guess
right because if we if it turns out that
we guessed wrong too often
uh or we didn't have a good guess at all
uh things might actually end up running
a little slower
so someone with armed with this
knowledge
and a copy of the implementation someone
could easily construct a counter example
where they say oh I have a program and
then now it runs five times as slow in
Python 311 than it did in Python 310.
but that's a very unrealistic program
that's that's just like an extreme fluke
it's a fun reverse engineering task
though oh yeah so there's uh
well people like fun yes so there's some
presumably heuristic
of what defines a momentum
of uh saying you know you seem to be
working adding two integers not two
generic types uh so how do you figure
out that heuristic I think that the
heuristic is actually we assume that the
weather tomorrow is going to be the same
as the weather today so you don't need
two days of the weather no
that is already so much better than than
guessing randomly that's so how do you
find this idea
hey I wonder if instead of adding to
generic types we uh you start assuming
that the weather tomorrow is the same as
the weather today where do you find the
idea for that because that ultimately
for you to do that you have to kind of
understand how people are using the
language right python is not the first
language to do a thing like this this is
a fairly well-known trick especially
from
other interpreted languages that had
reason to be sped up we occasionally
look at papers about hhvm which is for
Facebook's uh
efficient compiler for PHP there are
tricks known from the jvm and
sometimes it just comes from Academia
and so the trick here is that the type
itself doesn't the variable doesn't know
what type it is
so this is not a statically typed
language where you can
you you can get that for it to have a
shortcut to saying it's ins this is a
trick that is especially important for
uh for interpreted languages with
Dynamic typing because
if
if the compiler could read in the source
these X and Y that we're adding are
integers the compiler can just insert
the single add machine code that
Hardware machine instruction that exists
on every CPU and ditto for floats
but because in Python you don't
generally declare your the types of your
variables you you don't even declare the
existence of your variables they just
spring into existence when you first
assign them which is really cool and and
sort of helps those beginners because
there's less bookkeeping they have to
learn how to do before they can start
playing around with code but it makes
the the in interpretation of the code
less efficient and so we're we're sort
of
trying to
to make the interpretation more
efficient without losing the the super
Dynamic nature of the language that's
always the challenge